the mandalorians second season is
officially underway and with its second
episode the star wars series starts
building up to its next big adventure
fresh off their adventure in mars pelgo
mando and the child aka baby yoda
are back to their search for more
mandalorians and after an attempted
robbery which
naturally mando manages to thwart the
duo meets up with mechanic pelimoto
played by amy sedaris once again mato
tells mando that she needs a favor
and that a frog lady voiced by d bradley
baker needs help crossing the galaxy for
an incredibly important reason
her spawn need to be fertilized very
soon or her entire line will die out
to make matters more complicated mato
tells man though he can't use hyper
speed
during their journey if they do the frog
lady's eggs will die
though mando is hesitant about the
journey telling motto he's not a taxi
he ultimately agrees but doesn't notice
that the child is hungrily eyeing the
frog ladies container of eggs
unfortunately the journey doesn't go
smoothly after being tracked by x-wing
pilots suspicious of his ship and
identity
mando crash lands his ship on a
mysterious icy planet
that turns out to be home to a large
army of creepy crawly spider-like
creatures
called krichner after the child
inadvertently wakes the spiders the trio
fights for their lives
and with a final assist from the x-wing
pilots they set off for trask once again
but what lies ahead is anybody's guess
from the pilots who saved the day to the
potential mysteries of trask up ahead
here's the ending of the mandalorian
chapter 10
explained toward the end of the episode
things weren't looking so hot fermando
the child and the frog lady on the razor
crest
both because they're trapped on an ice
planet and also because they're moments
away from being devoured
and or crushed by a swarm of creepy ice
spiders big and small
salvation came in the form of two x-wing
pilots captain carson tever
and trapper wolf but given the fact that
the two space cops had been chasing the
razor crests earlier in the episode you
might be wondering just why they decided
to lend a helping hand
we ran the tabs on the razor crest
you have an arrest warrant for the
abduction of prisoner x6911
just who was prisoner x-6911 and two was
the new republic lieutenant davin
security records also show that you put
your own life in harm's way to try to
protect that of lieutenant davin from
the new republic correctional corps
the answers to these questions lie in
the previous season of the mandalorian
specifically season one's sixth chapter
called the prisoner
in that adventure mando teams up with a
bunch of cd criminals
to break a mysterious bad guy out of a
new republic prison ship
during the prison break they encounter
lieutenant davin mando tries to keep the
mercenary team from killing davin but it
doesn't go his way
however security equipment recorded his
attempt to keep davin alive
eventually all the criminals double
cross mando the prisoner they were hired
to free is an old enemy of his named
quinn
from there mando turns the tables on the
table turners and allows quinn and the
rest to be found by the new republic
coincidentally one of the x-wing pilots
who finds mando's gifts
is none other than trapper wolf
interestingly this deus ex wingina
isn't the first callback to the prisoner
in this episode earlier the frog lady
reserve a communication device with the
head of q90 or zero
wake up mandalorian cannot wait
until morning who happens to be one of
the mercenaries mando defeats during the
prison break
that moment definitely seems to
foreshadow the impending significance of
the prison breaks aftermath by the end
of this episode
all in all it's clear that the passenger
is just part of a larger story and in
fact the episode ended pretty abruptly
with frog lady mando and the child
headed off to complete their arduous
journey to trask
with that in mind fans are left to
wonder what's next in store for the trio
as they reach the planet obviously frog
lady has a mission
to find her husband and fertilize her
eggs before they die
mando also has a bone to pick with frog
lady's husband whom she claims has seen
mandalorians before
mando may be headed to find more of his
people but only two episodes in
it doesn't seem likely that he'll meet a
mandalorian and get closer to finding
any of the child's kin
so soon in the season also there's a
possibility that the child's ferocious
appetite may not be limited to this
particular episode
could there be some sort of significance
to him eating the frog lady's eggs that
we'll discover in the next episode will
the eggs make him sick in some way
that is not food don't do that again
which could potentially derail the
journey to trask if mando gets the frog
lady to trask safely will she notice how
many eggs are missing and turn against
mando and the child
more importantly will any other
adventurers from mando's past come back
to haunt him
or as it did in this case to help him we
didn't get any reappearances from
timwarra morrison's mystery character
you know the one who sure seems to be
boba fett will he be waiting for mando
and the rest on trask
or will we have to wait much longer for
him to reappear in any case the
passenger felt like the first half of a
two-part tail
so fans of the mandalorian will have to
wait a week to discover what lies in
store for mando
frog lady and the child on trask the
first two episodes of the mandalorian
second season are streaming on disney
plus now and new episodes will be
released
every friday check out one of our newest
videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the
mandalorian are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you